hey guys it is the 12th of February
today my name is Jess McDonald and you
are watching GameSpot news in the
biggest thing to have happened over the
last 24 hours the titanfall beta is now
open to sign up if you want in on either
the Xbox one or PC beta
I'd suggest you pup yourself over to
Titan Volcom forward slash fadeaway you
may or may not be granted a beta code
the matter itself is closed so if you
want in you'll have to get in line with
everybody else
since pre-ordering doesn't guarantee you
a spot not to worry if you didn't get
onto the signup page as soon as it went
up there because respawn instead
everybody has an equal chance of getting
in no matter when they register said
codes are supposed to go out before
11:59 p.m. PST on Feb 17 so if you're a
titanfall devotee that's when you'll
want to be refreshing your email have
you already signed up for the beta or
are you one of those people who just
wants to stop hearing about titanfall
let me know in the comments and of
course since a massive shooter is having
its launch it's sparked conversation
about how terrible that other massive
shooters launch was ea spent the day
defending battlefields controversial
launch which a lot of you guys like to
refer to using the technical term of
shitshow EA chief creative officer rich
Hillerman has said that while the game
did face numerous and occasionally
serious bugs it was still a great
success Hillerman sort of spent the rest
of this interview with Rock Paper
Shotgun saying I know we did things
wrong but that doesn't undermine the
commercial or technical achievements of
the title when it was suggested that
perhaps the game wasn't tested properly
he said that more than maybe 10,000
people were involved in the game's beta
test although he did admit the testing
on the then unreleased new consoles was
difficult do you reckon EA screwed up
massively or do you see where Hillerman
is coming from last night we've got some
more Titan fully stuff because the Xbox
one controller is getting a fix for the
game respawn instruments are currently
working with Microsoft on a patch to
make the analog controls of the Xbox one
controller a tad less to achieve for the
shooter Microsoft are also working to
patch up the consoles multiplayer
experience in Antibes
for titanfall's launched in March on top
of all that race one design lead Justin
Hendry has said they're also working
together on formulating a new version of
Xboxes 1080p upscaler which should
ideally improve the visuals of games
that aren't native to that resolution
let me know if you are happy about these
improvements either in the comments down
below or you can do so on my Twitter
where I'm at just with Donald that's it
for me today but be sure to join me
again tomorrow we'll have more on the
new Z stuff I will see you soon